Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
Question.
Now it does seem like I'm a cybernetic organism.
Living Tissue.
This episode is brought to you by helix sleep.
I recently moved into a new home and when I needed beds,
where did I go?
I went to helix and I paid for them with my own monies.
I tried all sorts of mattresses.
Some of you saw me soliciting feedback and ideas on social media.
I tested a ton and I ended up on Helix.
They offer mattresses personalized to your preferences and sleeping style
without costing thousands of dollars.
It's chicken out.
He let's sleep.com forward slash Tim and you can take,
they're very simple,
two to three minutes sleep quiz to get started.
That's a diagnostic and they can build your mattress from there and ensure that
it is something you will absolutely love.
The quiz helps determine the type of mattress that is best for you by asking all
sorts of questions about your sleep behavior,
such as if you tend to lie on your back side or stomach as well as your body
type for couples,
they can even personalize each side of the mattress there.
Customer service is phenomenal.
My assistant,
my researcher,
I had them all test helix and the customer service is really outstanding.
The mattress arrives within a week and the shipping is completely free.
You can try the mattress then for a hundred nights and if you're not happy,
they'll pick it up and offer a full refund.
So checking out to personalize your sleep experience.
Visit Helix,
sleep.com forward slash Tim and you can get $50 off of your custom mattress.
It's checking out.
He looks sleep.com forward slash.
Tim,
this episode is brought to you by legal zoom.
I've used legal zoom for many of my businesses and Matt Mullenweg as one
example.
He's been on the podcast CEO of Automattic now worth more than a billion dollars
first incorporated.
His company were on legal zoom.
When you run your own business,
you know that time equals money.
So why waste your valuable time dealing with issues that legal zoom can solve
for you?
More than 2 million people have used legal zoom to start their businesses,
but their services don't end at the beginning.
Legal Zoom has a network of independent attorneys licensed in all 50 states.
They can provide all the advice you need.
Nuts and bolts start to finish,
and you don't need to worry about billable hours because legal zoom isn't a law
firm.
That way.
You have upfront pricing and complete clarity.
Legal Zoom is a reliable resource that more than a million people have already
trusted to help them with their businesses and all sorts of different ways,
and that includes setting up will's doing a proper trademark search,
forming an LLC,
setting up a nonprofit,
or finding simple cease and desist letter templates.
So check them out.
Legal zoom.com take a look today to see how they can make your better,
easier,
faster,
and more effective.
Enter Promo Code Tim Tim at checkout to save 15% that's legalzoom.com and code
Tim for 15% off.
Good evening.
This is Jocko Willink and I am standing in as the host for the Tim Ferriss show
and I'm doing some talking because right now Mr Tim Ferriss can't talk to you
himself because he is in a a silent retreat where he's remaining in complete
silence for I think 10 days and it's not just silence,
it's actually also no books,
no computers,
no phones.
Obviously it's just pure silence alone with your thoughts.
Not exactly,
but what I would want to do,
but it sounds kind of crazy and it sounds like something Tim Ferris would do,
but in the meantime,
like I said,
I'm here to guest host this show,
which is awesome.
I appreciate that opportunity and thanks to Tim Ferris for giving me that
opportunity.
Now,
a little bit about my background.
First,
if you want to know about me,
one of the best places to find out about me is actually on this podcast as well.
Tim Ferriss,
episode number 107 and that was released in September of 2015 and that was the
first time I was ever interviewed really for anything.
And I had been in the seal teams for 20 years.
I'd never done any interview,
I'd never had any social media,
didn't have a website.
I really didn't exist in the public eye at all.
And so my background is that I grew up in a small new England town.
I enlisted in the navy after high school.
I went through boot camp,
I went to seal training,
I spent some time at seal team one in the 90s and eventually got picked up for a
commissioning program,
which meant I was going to become an officer in the seal teams and move into a
leadership position.
And eventually once I did that,
the war started in September,
September 11th,
2001 and from there I deployed to Iraq as a seal platoon commander.
And then as a seal task unit commander when I was a task unit commander,
I fought in the battle of Ramadi,
Ramadi,
Iraq,
the capital of Al Anbar province,
and very tough fighting in incredible effort by the soldiers and Marines on the
ground.
And also the guys that were with me as well from my seal task unit and ended up
being the most highly decorated special operations unit from the Iraq war.
And incredible sacrifices were made for that victory.
And when I got back from that deployment to Iraq,
I took over the training for the west coast seal teams and the training that I
took over as the training where you've got the boat on your head or you're
carrying the logs around or you're doing a bunch of pushups and pull ups and
runs and swims.
It's the,
the real training we're seals actually learn to be seals to shoot,
move and communicate to fire,
maneuver to close with and destroy the enemy.
And they learn about combat leadership.
And I did that for my last few years in the seal teams,
taught that and then I retired in 2010 and when I did that I started working
with companies with businesses and helping out with their leadership and their
management and that developed into a leadership and management consulting
company,
which is called echelon front that I run with my buddy and former teammate Leif
Babin who was one of the platoon commanders that worked for me in the battle of
Ramadi.
And we wrote a book together which was called extreme ownership.
And that is how I ended up being on Tim's podcast for the first time.
We had some mutual friends,
Kirk Parsley and doctor Peter Attia and they made the intro and that's how I
ended up on this podcast the first time in that book,
extreme ownership is a book about leadership,
really it's combat leadership lessons learned and tested on the battlefield that
that we then talked to the next generation of seals and now we're out there
teaching these leadership principles to businesses and teams and organizations
throughout the civilian world.
And also in law enforcement,
in fire departments,
in any type of organization.
So that's what we're doing now.
And as that book was launching,
like I said,
I went on Tim's podcast.
It was awesome.
And when we got done with that podcast,
when Tim Press Stop on the recorder,
he said,
you should really have your own podcast.
And I kind of like,
you know,
I listened to him but I had a bunch of stuff going on in the book was coming out
and whatnot.
And then Joe Rogan heard that podcast and asked me to come on his podcast.
And in the middle of that podcast,
Joe Rogan said,
you should have your own podcast.
So I guess when Tim Ferriss and Joe Rogan tell you,
you should have your own podcast,
then you should listen.
And I did.
And so I started my own podcast,
which is called Jocko podcast.
And really it's a podcast about human nature and it's human nature as viewed
through the lens of war and other human struggles and is definitely focused on
leadership.
But it also often reveals the dark side of mankind.
And the podcast can get pretty heavy and pretty dark,
but it's not all like that.
And I also know as we did the podcast,
as I continue to put it out there,
I also talked about all kinds of other things about life and in how I live about
surfing and about Jujitsu and about working out and about eating in how I eat
and sleeping and how I sleep and how to wake up earlier and how to overcome
procrastination and how to accomplish goals and how to get the most out of life
and all those kinds of things.
Your basic winning.
And in there I,
I wrote a book for kids and a book that I wrote for kids is called the way of
the warrior kid
and it's,
you know,
it's about a kid that's having a tough time at school.
He didn't know how to,
couldn't do any pull ups and he didn't know his times tables,
so he kind of felt stupid and he didn't know how to swim because he was afraid
of the water and he was getting picked on at school.
And the last day of school,
everything kind of comes crashing down on him and he goes home all sad.
But when he gets home he remembers that his uncle is coming to stay with him for
the summer and his uncle was a seal in the seal teams.
And so his uncle finds out what these problems are that the kid is suffering
through and says,
look,
oh you can't,
you can't swim.
You don't know how to do any pull ups or you can't do any pull ups.
You don't know your times tables,
you're getting picked on at school.
We can handle those problems.
So they go on a little journey and the uncle,
Uncle Jake teaches young mark how to overcome all these challenges.
And so that book came out,
but people were asking for sort of details on the aspect of my life about,
you know,
not about the leadership stuff,
but about my sort of kind of operating system.
And so eventually I put that down,
kind of my mode of living into the way I live.
And this book is called discipline equals freedom of field manual.
And it just came out October 17th and that's how I ended up doing this podcast
for Tim because like I said,
Tim is,
I guess fortunately or unfortunately depending on how you're looking at it.
Tim is not allowed to talk right now and so he,
but he had read the book just before he went into his period of silence and he
wanted me to come on while he was not able to speak and talk about some of the
high points that Mike,
he,
that he thought would be a useful introduction to people that listen to his
podcast.
So that's why I'm here.
If you were expecting Tim,
I apologize.
I know that's always a bummer when you're expecting to have that person that
you,
you know,
and you're,
you're anticipating hearing their voice and then it turns out not to be that
person.
So if you've made it this far,
thank you.
And here we go.
The book is broken into two sections.
The sections,
first section is called faults and the second section is called actions.
And the faults section is about,
well basically it's what goes through my head.
It's how I view and how I think about things and Tim wanted me to focus on the
actions part,
but for one example of what is in the thoughts category.
I'm going to the book here.
This is directly from the book discipline equals freedom field manual.
Here we go.
People want to know how to stop laziness.
They want to know how to stop procrastination.
They have an idea in their head,
maybe even a vision,
but they don't know where to start.
So they ask and they say,
where do I start?
When is the best time to start?
And I have a simple answer here and now that's it.
You want to improve.
You want to get better.
You want to get on a workout program or a clean diet or start a new business.
You want to write a book or make a movie or build a house or a computer or an
APP.
Where do you start?
You start right here.
When do you start?
You start right now.
You initiate action.
You Go,
here is the reality.
That idea isn't going to execute itself.
That book isn't going to write itself.
Those weights out in the gym,
they aren't going to move themselves.
You have to do it and you have to do it now.
So stop thinking about it,
stop dreaming about it,
stop researching every aspect of it and reading all about it and debating the
pros and cons of it.
Start doing it.
Okay,
take that first step and make it happen.
Get after it here and now.
So that's the kind of things that are in the book.
The first part of the book,
which again is called thoughts and like I said,
the second part is what I actually do to implement those thoughts into my life.
And of course Tim being Mr Pragmatic,
like how do we get to it,
how do we make it happen?
He asked me to detail some of those for you and one of the things that he wanted
me to talk about was early morning training and what role getting up early
because I get up early in the morning,
what role that plays in my life and why I kind of maintained that and have
maintained that for a long time.
And there's one section that talks about kind of a,
a little psychological edge that I believe the waking up early in the morning
gives anyone that wakes up early in the morning.
So here's a little chunk of the book where I talk about that psychological edge.
Okay.
There are a slew of psychological advantages that come from early morning
physical training.
First,
there is a psychological when over the enemy.
Knowing that you are working harder than your adversaries gives you an
advantage.
It gives you confidence that you can overcome them and battle.
Another advantage to waking up early and working out hard is that it demands
discipline to do both.
Now,
some scientists have claimed that discipline dissipates.
The more it is used,
that willpower is a finite resource that is reduced every time it is used
throughout the day.
This is wrong.
That does not happen to the contrary.
I believe and studies have shown that discipline and willpower do not go down as
they're called into action,
they actually get stronger.
This is obvious if you actually try the experiment yourself before you go to
bed.
Plan,
what workout you're going to do in the morning stage,
your workout clothes so you don't even have to think about them when you get up.
Write down a list of things you need to accomplish the next day.
Set your alarm clock for 4:30 AM and go to sleep
when the alarm clock goes off,
get up,
put on your pre-staged clothes,
brush your teeth and go get your workout on hard.
Get done,
shower,
get dressed and begin to crush the lists of tasks you made for the day.
When it was time for breakfast,
see what happens.
You won't want to eat junk.
You won't want that disgusting donut.
You will want some eggs and bacon and that will happen a lunch too.
You're feeling good,
energized.
You don't want to eat that worthless calories of pizza or French fries.
You want fuel,
good fuel to rebuild your body.
Clean fuel that keeps your mind sharp.
When you're on the path,
you want to stay on the path.
Unfortunately,
the opposite is also true.
Once you step off the path,
you tend to stray far.
When you don't prepare what you need to do.
The next day when you sleep in and skip your workout and you don't start
attacking the tasks that you have because you didn't write them down the night
before.
That is when you make bad decisions.
That is when your will and discipline fail.
You figure you might as well have that donut,
have that doughnut for breakfast and once you've done that,
might as well put down four or five pieces of pizza for lunch.
It doesn't matter anymore.
You're off the path and that is a disaster.
Do your will didn't break.
It never showed up in the first place.
So get on the path of discipline and stay on the path.
Discipline be gets disciplined,
will propagates more will hold the line across the line and victory will be
yours.
So
that's why I wake up early in the morning and workout.
And also in the book I talk about how you actually start getting up early in the
morning because this is a big challenge for a lot of people.
I know I get it and there's a bunch of ways to do this and one of the most
important things to allow you to get up early in the morning is to go to bed
earlier.
But going to bed earlier is also a challenge.
And again,
I talk about this in the book,
but how do you,
how,
what's the most important thing to,
to put into place to go to bed earlier is number one,
you want to be tired when you get to the end of the day,
you want to be tired.
That's how you get to go to bed earlier.
Number two,
turn off the Internet because they've got these little people that are
programming things into the interwebs that are truly just meant to get you to
click.
One more time.
Just click one more time and watch one more.
One more video,
one more stupid video that's not getting you anything,
not improving you in any way.
So turn off the Internet.
And if you,
if you need to do something than read a book,
pick up a book and read a book
and the most important thing to allow you to go to bed earlier,
the most important thing you can do is actually get up earlier,
right?
That's what happens you when you get up earlier,
well then you're more tired by the end of the day and then you can go to sleep
and that that gets you in the right pattern.
So the way you start getting,
the way you start going to bed earlier is by getting up earlier.
And again,
I detailed this and the way that pattern kind of unfolds itself in the book.
Now another thing that Tim wanted me to hit on was my actual workouts,
like what my workouts look like from week to week.
And I'll say this,
I have a bunch of,
a bunch of kind of standard workouts that I use and they may vary a little bit
depending on what I'm feeling like or what is needed.
Or maybe I've got some little injury that I have to cover up or,
or maybe I'm really tired from some other workout that I did,
so I need to make an adjustment or maybe I haven't worked out in a few days so
we need to go even harder.
So there's little adjustments that go by and,
and I actually took a lot of these standard workouts that I have and I put them
in the book.
Again,
this is something that people really wanted to hear from me,
what my workouts actually were.
And so I put them in there and,
and they go from the beginner level from,
from people that really haven't worked out before,
all the way to intermediate,
all the way up to advanced.
And I've been able to,
I actually own a gym in California,
a big mixed martial arts gym,
but we've got all kinds of,
you know,
we've got Olympic lifting,
we've got,
we've got everything in there.
And so I've seen people and train people at all levels from do you know,
total non athlete that haven't done anything active in years all the way to the
highest level athletes that are fighting professionally in the UFC.
So I've seen and brought people through those different,
those different categories over,
over the past 10 years that I've been training civilians.
So,
uh,
that's,
that's what this book contains,
is what those are like.
Now I also go after different goals because you want to be chasing something.
I,
at least I do.
I want to be chasing something.
I want to be trying to achieve something,
but I don't just continually chase the same thing.
So sometimes I'll be trying to,
you know,
maybe I'll spend a month trying to increase my dead lift and get,
get my dead lift up up there.
And then sometimes I'll be just trying to run and get my,
my three mile time grown or my four mile time run down.
Or sometimes I'm trying to Max out and pull ups and see how many pull ups I can
get.
And so I'm kind of always chasing some goal of some kind.
And I never go too far in one direction because I think that that would not suit
me for the way I live.
For instance,
if I was just trying to get a massive deadlift,
which is awesome,
but if that's my sole purpose is to get a massive dead lift,
well then I'm going to be as big and strong as possible.
But that's obviously going to hurt my mobility.
It's going to hurt like my cardio.
And so I get to a point where,
you know,
I'm maybe some percentage of my percent of my capability and then once I get to
that percentage and,
and I get to that point where I'm really going to have to change my lifestyle in
order to increase beyond that.
That's when I say,
okay,
you know what,
I've,
this is one of my dead lift is out right now.
Let's start looking at how many pull ups I can do or let's,
let's start seeing one other exercise I can move on to and find some other
challenge.
So that's sorta what my,
my workouts are like.
I'm always chasing something.
The other thing with this is people get really fanatical about working out in,
in they get into the,
where their workout becomes a form of religion.
And,
and that's one of the reasons that I never really talk specifically about what I
do for my workouts because,
um,
don't really like to preach about,
you know,
you should do this or you should do that.
So I'm,
but people are interested.
So that's,
that's why I put it out there and it is,
you know,
the kind of training that I do at depth.
It definitely has been effective for me over the years in my various jobs.
So,
but I'm not a person that says,
Hey,
my way is better than everyone else's way.
I'm not one of those people.
I'm not saying that at all.
Actually there's people that know more than me and there's people that have the
better methodologies are different methodologies that work well for their system
and that's cool.
That's cool.
If you,
if you want to text you or whatever,
put on social media 8,000 times that you have something better.
That's awesome.
I appreciate your,
your input but I've been doing what I'm doing done for a long time and it's not
a religion to me it's just a cool way of working out.
So my workouts are are kind of split into some broad movements.
The broad movement movements are pull,
push,
lift and squat and how those breakout pole is basically centered around pull ups
and in seal training you do a lot of pull ups and pull ups.
Are obviously important because you've got to be able to pull yourself up,
climb ladders,
all those things and so,
and it's also good to know that you can move your body weight around.
So pull ups are a huge part of my workouts and pull ups is what the pull day is
centered on that and do all different kinds of pullups,
close grip and narrow grip and wide grip and ring pull ups and and climbing
ropes and and obviously pull ups on the pull up bar.
And so,
so that's what the poll day is,
is based on the push day is again it goes back,
it's rooted in seal training,
which is the push day is basically centered around pushups and dips.
And so again all the different kinds of pushups and all the different kinds of
dips,
ring dips,
bar dips,
pushups,
close grip,
push ups,
wide grip,
dive bomber pushups,
all of these different types of pushups that you can do.
That's what that push day is centered on.
The lift day is,
for lack of a better way to explain this to the lift day for me is primarily
about getting things off the ground and over my head.
So,
so that means dead lifts,
it means cleans,
it means clean and jerk.
He means press,
it means snatches,
it means handstand pushups,
those kinds of exercises.
That's what the lift the day is to me.
And then finally squat,
which could also be called leg day,
but that obviously focuses on all different kinds of squatting for back squats
and front squat and overhead squat and all the other types of variations of
squats that there are.
But also it's not just squatting cause I'll do plyometrics and sprinting and
calisthenics that are leg focused.
So those are the kind of the four categories,
pull,
push,
lift and squat.
And then on top of those I do gut,
which I guess it's what normal people kind of call core or abs,
but
I just have always called a gut.
Again,
that's rooted in the seal teams.
They would when I was a new guy in 1990 whatever,
they'd say,
we're going to do some gut work.
And what that meant was you were going to work out your abs,
you're going to do sit ups,
you're going to do Russian twist,
you're gonna do all flutter kicks,
all those things.
And,
and then on top of that,
I do metabolic conditioning and,
and the way I do metabolic conditioning,
which is basically that means you're going to be breathing hard,
really hard for either of short,
intense amount of time or maybe a little bit longer.
But that's,
that's what I definitely do metabolic conditioning.
And the reason I do metabolic conditioning is still that I'm in good shape so I
can sustain a high output for short bursts and multiple short burst and over
longer periods of time.
And I'm mixed that in sometimes with the workout itself.
And sometimes I do it before the workout,
sometimes I do it after the workout.
And I mean if you,
if you talk about what my workouts consist of as far as time goes,
my workouts just depend on what's going on in my world.
In that day,
some of my workouts are very quick and I can get them done in less than 10
minutes and they make you want to throw up.
And at the same time,
some of them,
sometimes I'm working out for three hours,
you know,
maybe doing singles and doubles and triples on,
on weights for heavy exercises.
So,
and it depends.
It depends on what I'm doing,
what my current goal is,
how I set those up.
And it also depends on what life is throwing at me.
Obviously all out on the road somewhere,
you can't always do heavy squats because your hotel gym only has two 35 pound
dumbbells,
which really puts the heavy squats out of the picture.
So you gotta be able to adapt and make something else happen.
So Tim asked that I talk about what an actual series of workouts from me would
look like.
And so like I said in the book,
I actually put they'll workouts in the book.
And so I'll kind of read through some of these workouts a few days.
So you get the feel for,
for what it is.
And these are,
I went right to the advanced workouts.
Again,
there's beginner,
intermediate,
advanced.
Maybe I'll talk a little bit about some of the beginner ones too,
but there is a place to start.
If you can't do anything,
you can still get started,
but the advanced,
here's a,
here's an example of what I would do on a pole day for,
for an advanced workout.
So here we go.
The primary work is going to be 30 muscle ups and a muscle up is on rings.
You can do them on a bar too.
I do.
I'm usually on rings.
I'm muscle up is where you hold on two rings or a Bar,
like,
like you're going to do a pull up,
you do a pull up,
but you pull yourself all the way up and then press through until you've done a
dip and now you're in the dip position either on top of the bar or on above the
rings.
So it's called a muscle up.
If you can't understand my description,
then you can go to youtube and look up muscle up and you'll see him.
So 30 muscle ups and then a hundred dead hang pull ups and then a hundred
kipping pull ups and I'll do all those four time as fast as I can.
And then when I get done with those,
I'll do some hang cleans,
which again this is a place where you want might want to go to youtube and check
out what a hang clean is.
Youtube is an incredible instrument and tool for,
for trying to learn.
That being said,
when you go and you look at the youtube video,
what you think you're doing is not what you probably are doing.
And that's why getting a coach to help you as very important.
I remember one time I was coaching a guy in boxing and inboxing you,
you're supposed to move your head from side to side.
There's certain movements that your head is supposed to have.
And I was,
I was watching him do it and he said,
hey,
you know,
how's my head movement look?
And I hadn't trained him in awhile.
He said,
he said,
how's my head movement looking at him looking?
And I said,
well,
go ahead and,
and let me see it.
And so he started doing it and his,
it was,
it was hilarious because his head was staying absolutely still,
but his shoulders were low.
He would lift his left shoulder,
then lift his right shoulder,
then lift his left shoulder than lift his right shoulder.
But his head was staying still.
And I said,
okay,
it's okay.
Just come here and look in the mirror.
Because when you shadow box,
you use a mirror.
And he looked in the mirror and he saw what was happening.
And in his mind,
his head was moving back and forth from left to right.
But in reality,
the only thing that was moving was his shoulders lifting up.
So you have to be very careful when you're,
when you're lifting weights that you,
you,
you truly are doing what you think you're doing in.
The easiest way to do that is to have a coach coming to watch you do your
movements.
So for instance,
the hang clean is a,
is a,
is a movement that I would do next in this workout and I would just do probably
six sets,
six sets of between three to six repetitions.
And again,
I'm just trying to maintain good form and then get done without.
So I've done 30 muscle ups,
I've done a hundred dead hang pull ups in a dead hang,
pull up.
If you don't know what that is,
that's where you,
you don't use any motion of your body,
you're using pure strength.
And then I do 100 kipping bulbs.
Oh.
And before everyone thinks I'm lying or a or whatever,
I can't do a hundred dead hang pull ups in a row.
I can't do 30 muscle ups in a row.
I can't do a hundred kipping pull ups in a row.
I,
I'm what I'm,
when I talk about doing these,
I talk about doing as many as I can and then I have to stop and shake it out and
then I jump up and do some more.
So maybe for my hundred dead hang pullups maybe my first set,
I only get 14 dead.
Hang,
pull ups,
I drop off the bar,
I shake it out,
I jump up there and I do another 10 so now I'm at 24 and then I can't do it
anymore.
So I dropped off the bar.
Maybe I get another set of 10 then I'm at 34 and so that's what I'm gonna do
until I get to a hundred when I get to a hundred dead hang pullups and now it's
time for me to do kipping pull ups.
Then I'll do the same thing.
Maybe the first set I do 40 kipping pull ups.
Once I've done 40 I shake off the bar,
our jump off the bar,
shake it out a little bit,
I'll jump up back on the bar.
And now I do 20 so I'm up to 60 and now I drop off the bar.
I'd do it again.
I got up to 80 so,
so that's what I'm talking about.
You're going to break up these sets until you can get the number that you're
aiming for.
So then after I'd done 30 muscle ups,
a hundred dead hang pullups,
a hundred kipping pull ups.
Then I jump into doing some six sets of hang cleans with a weight that allows
you to do three to six repetitions per cent while you're still maintaining good
form.
And it's,
again,
it's critical to maintain good forms.
And then I would do five sets of reverse curls followed by regular curls.
Now
I used to,
I went through the stage of saying all curls,
you know,
those are,
those are just the exercise for looking good.
And I was kind of derogatory on doing curls,
but I changed my mind,
I would say a few years ago I changed my mind because,
well I hurt my bicep and when I hurt my bicep,
I said to myself,
well,
maybe my bicep isn't as strong as it should be.
And the tendons going into it maybe aren't as strong as they should be.
And so maybe I should do a little bit of isolation training on those muscles to
make them stronger.
And so that's what I started doing it.
And it's,
it's worked out well.
My,
my bicep healed and it's hasn't been injured since then.
So.
So that's an exercise that even though people might think,
oh,
curls,
that's a bodybuilding exercise,
why would I do that?
I don't care about looking good,
I just want to be strong.
Well it makes you stronger too.
So that's,
that's the curls.
Then from there I would do some gut work.
The,
the gut work I have listed on this particular workup is a hundred v ups,
which is when you're laying flat on your back,
arms extended above your head,
feet extended as far as you can,
and then you close up like a Jack Knife in a v position until you touch your
toes to your fingers.
And then you lay back down,
do a hundred of those and then a hundred Russian twists,
which is when your feet are up in the air,
your,
your torso is up in the air and you're bringing your hands back and forth from
side to side.
Get done with that.
And then I would do a little metcon work.
So metabolic conditioning.
And for this one here I have listed do four sets of cleans and pull ups with the
following repetition.
So I do a set of 20 cleans,
followed by 20 pull ups than 15 cleans,
followed by 15 pull ups,
then 10 cleans followed by 10 pull ups than five cleans followed by five bulbs.
And that's what I would do.
And for the cleans I'd use probably about 60% of my body weight to do cleans.
And there you get a little,
you get a little cardio work during that you will be breathing hard,
I promise if you give that a shot.
So there's an example of a workout that I would do and for my pole day,
you know,
um,
I'll talk about for let's just do one more,
go,
go for a push day,
push day,
here's a,
another workout.
So for this push day,
I would be doing three minutes on and one minute rest of the following
exercises,
ring dips,
which are dips using gymnastics,
rings,
ring pushups,
dips,
clap pushups,
deep pushups.
So I do those deep pushups in,
in parallettes,
which are something or you,
something where you can go deeper than your normal range of motion if you're on
the floor.
And then just regular push ups on the floor.
And so I'd set my timer for three minutes of work and followed by one minute of
rest,
and then I'd go through the ring,
dips as many as I can in three minutes.
Then rest of minute,
and then do the same thing for the,
the ring pushups,
the dips,
the clap,
push ups,
the deep pushups,
and then regular pushups.
And once my time is up,
and this is something I always do,
is when it gets to that last set,
the last set is kind of the easiest exercise.
So regular pushups are easier than clap pushups and they're easier than deep
pushups.
But I get there,
I'm always going to do a hundred at that last,
that last set.
So,
and again,
that doesn't mean I can do a hundred pushups in a row,
especially after I've done all this other work.
But I will continue to take rests and break up the set until I can get to what I
want to do until I get to that number of 100 now I get done with that and I
would do some repetitions of the snatch movement,
the snatches a really hard movement to do.
And again,
youtube has some good visuals of what looks like to do is snatch.
But if you're going to start snatching,
you really need to get someone to watch you and a good qualified coach that can,
that can watch you and make sure that you're doing these exercises right.
And you know,
I would do some repetitions of that just to keep,
just to build my own muscle memory and try and get better at the exercise I'm
not great at at at that exercise.
And then do some gut hold a plank for five minutes.
And then for the metcon,
for the metabolic conditioning,
I do three rounds of Max burpees in three minutes with one minute of rest
between the rounds and that right there,
that'll inflict some damage on you.
If you go hard,
you're actually two minutes of burpees can crush people.
If you go as hard as you possibly can for two minutes of burpees,
it can.
It can leave a mark and leave a mark.
I will tell you now for the lifting,
again,
you gotta be really careful and make sure that you're,
your technique is absolutely critical and you gotta.
If you sacrifice your form,
you will.
It will not make you stronger.
It will actually make you injured in,
I wrote that in the book.
That right,
they're sacrificing proper form will not make you stronger.
It will only make you injured.
So try and find a good coach that's going to teach you these things.
And for this,
for instance,
on a lift day in this,
in this workout that I've gotten the book,
it's you get,
I would do eight to 10 sets of clean and jerks building up to four sets that
with a weight that allows me to do two to four repetitions.
So I'm just doing eight to 10 sets,
taking some time in between.
You said this is a day where I'm trying to get stronger,
trying to build my strength,
trying to build my clean and jerk.
So it's pretty simple.
It's pretty straight,
straightforward.
Eight to 10 sets of clean and jerks and I'm doing,
I'm trying to build up to where I do four of the sets are with a pretty
heavyweight that I can only do two,
three,
maybe four times get done with that.
I'm going to do some hanging windshield wipers for my gut,
which is when you hang from a bar and you bring your legs back and forth,
like I said,
a windshield wipers,
they're brutal by the way.
So be,
be uh,
be ready for that.
Sounds all sounds all easy.
They're not.
And then for the Metcon,
I would do this here about 60% of body weight,
30 reps,
repetitions of clean and jerks without putting the bar down.
Once you get done with that rest,
two minutes,
do 20 repetitions of clean and jerks with the same way.
Get done with that rest,
two minutes,
all those without putting the bar down.
Then the last one you performed 10 repetitions,
so you do,
you get about 60% of your body weight.
You do 30 reps,
don't put the bar down during the 30 reps.
Once you're done with a third rupture,
you can put the bar down,
rest for two minutes,
then pick up the bar again,
do 20 reps,
same weight.
When you're done with that,
put the bar down rest for two minutes,
two minutes is up,
do it again,
10 repetitions and then you're done.
That's going to get you something.
It's a tough workout I can assure you.
And lastly for for a squat day,
what I would do here is just going to do some,
some,
some squats.
I would do 50 overhead squats with about 60% body weight.
And again,
this is something you're gonna break up.
You're going to do what you can.
You get done with 50 reps of that,
you're going to do 50 front squats with about 80% of your body weight and then
50 back squats with your body weight.
That's it.
Pretty simple.
Get done with that.
Do some gut hundred sit ups with 20% of your body weight sitting on your chest
and the metcon is to run two miles.
And I usually like to do some kind of a run when I get done squatting because it
kind of loosens up the legs and get some of that lactic acid moved out of there.
So those are some examples of the workouts that I do.
And then I would,
I normally just go right back into the workout.
However,
sometimes after a brutalized myself for multiple days in a row,
I feel like crap.
And so I might take a rest day and what I do on a rest day is I'll still do
something.
Maybe we'll just go for a jog.
Maybe we'll go for a swim,
maybe let's go in there and do some,
some burpees to warm up and then just do some good stretching.
But I don't like to take a lot of days off,
scheduled days off because I think life brings me days off when the more often
than I need.
So whether it's your traveling or whether it's your water heater breaks or your
car broke down or your kid got sick and you have to miss your workout.
That's when I take my days off when I'm forced to buy life.
Now again,
inside this book,
I've got beginner routines as well.
And the beginner routines,
or actually I'll look at one right now.
Um,
for instance,
if for a pullup workout,
all you're going to do is eight sets of Max pull up.
So you might only be able to do three pullups and guess what?
You're going to do three pullups then and then you'll rest for a few minutes,
then you'll do another three.
Or maybe you're only doing two and then you do that eight times.
And if you can't do any pull ups at all,
there's an answer to that as well.
You jump up on the bar and you hold yourself up there as long as you can and you
just do the negative work.
So,
and then you get done with that.
You do some sit ups,
as many as you can in two minutes and then run 400 meters,
two times.
That's,
that's a beginner workout up out inside this book.
So I started off pretty easy and then it escalates as you get in better shape.
And by the way,
you can do that workout right there.
It's a beginner workout,
but you can do it if you do it.
If you're advanced and you do it,
you'll still crush yourself.
Cause instead of doing three pull ups,
your first set,
you'll be doing 58 and then you'll,
you'll be getting your workout on.
So again,
that's,
that's the way the,
the workout book or the book is set up as far as workout goes.
I also talk a little bit about training on the road cause I spend a lot of time
traveling with the echelon front,
our consulting company.
So I'm in hotel rooms a lot and I got some stuff in there about the kind of
workouts that I do in hotel gyms.
You know,
sometimes I'll,
for instance,
throw a towel over a piece of gym equipment if they don't have a pull up bar or
I'll go into a parking garage because just about every parking garage has some
kind of plumbing or piping up in the ceiling.
And so you can find a place that you can jump up and you can do some pull ups,
be careful,
don't,
don't break the plumbing and cause massive amounts of damage.
But you find a good pipe where you find,
uh,
an I beam that you can get,
you can get ahold of and you'd go there and you do some followups.
So there's that of the,
I spend many times doing dips between treadmills.
I don't really like treadmills if I'm going to run them and go run.
But the,
the,
the treadmills have big handles on them.
So I'll,
I'll kind of move those around the floor a little bit and get some dips on
those.
And sometimes,
in fact,
oftentimes it's just a hotel room floor with their nasty carpets.
And on those nasty carpets,
I'll do burpees,
I'll do push ups,
I'll do gut exercises,
handstand pushups,
squats,
pistols,
which are one legged squats.
I'll do whatever and I'll just get crazy with the calisthenics.
And a lot of times also when I'm on the road is I don't have a lot of time
because I'm meet with a client and then I'm speaking and then I'm going to a
meeting.
And so my,
my work and I flew in and I got in late.
And so lot of times I'll just be doing some kind of a quick workout to maintain
the discipline,
to maintain the discipline and to get some level of workout and to get the blood
flowing because I think it's bad when you don't wake up and do something.
I always feel groggy for the day.
So one of my favorite quick workouts to do is,
is a hundred burpees for time.
One minute rest a hundred burpees for time.
Get some of that again,
it should probably take you less than less than 20 minutes for sure.
And once you get done with that,
you'll,
you'll have the blood flowing and you'll feel better about yourself.
Again,
all those are in the book and yeah,
you can check them out.
Now another section of the book that Tim wanted me to talk about was,
I talk about martial arts in the book,
and I've been training martial arts for a long time and there's various types of
martial arts.
There's striking,
there's grappling and there's weapons.
These are the kind of the broad,
the broad martial arts categories,
right?
Striking,
which is when you're hitting people grappling,
which is when you're grabbing people and using weapons,
obviously there's all kinds of different weapons from knives to swords to sticks
to firearms,
guns and it.
So I talk about those things,
but I,
I talk a lot about Jujitsu,
which,
which I think is the best base to have for martial arts.
And Tim liked this part where I talked about why to start with Brazilian Jujitsu
and how it should be taught for self defense.
So here we're going to the book where I talk about why to start with Brazilian
Jujitsu.
Start with Brazilian Jujitsu.
It is a form of grappling that is highly advanced because for the most part the
actual fighting takes place on the ground.
This is a key point because our first form of self defense is to get away yes to
run.
If you are confronted by another person or a group of people,
the best thing you can do is run away.
Avoid the conflict.
This is relatively easy.
If someone is trying to strike you with punches or kicks,
they do not have control over you so you can simply run away from them.
You have one.
Okay?
The problem comes in a self defense situation.
When someone is grabbing you now they are preventing your first line of self
defense running away.
As soon as someone grabs you,
you are in a grappling scenario and one of the most critical parts of Brazilian
Jujitsu is escaping from someone's grip.
So you can run.
Oftentimes an attacker will take you to the ground in order to prevent you from
escaping their grip.
When this happens,
the ability to ground fight is used not to stay on the ground,
but to get up and get away from the attacker.
The first goal of a beginner in Jujitsu is not to get the fight to the ground,
but to get up off the ground and get away.
This is an important distinction from people who believe the goal of self
defense and Jujitsu is to get the attacker to the ground.
This is not true.
The goal is to get away,
but as has been seen over and over again,
fights often end up on the ground and therefore a person must be prepared for
it.
Not Training in Jujitsu because you don't want to go to the ground is like not
learning how to swim because you don't want to go in the water.
It doesn't make sense.
The safest way to deal with the water is to be comfortable in it.
Just as being comfortable on the ground is the best way to deal with that
scenario.
Should it unfold in real life.
So that's one of those things that people understandably so if,
if they learn that,
if they think that Jujitsu,
if you get attacked,
what you're gonna do is grab someone and pull him to the ground.
That's,
that's not what the goal is.
The goal is to get away from people.
So,
uh,
unfortunately in many fights they end up on the ground because if you start
hitting someone,
their defense might be to grab you and when they grab you,
now you're in a grappling scenario.
So that is why Jujitsu is very important.
Now there's other great martial arts and I talk about them in the book as well.
One of the things that Tim asked me about is if I was teaching a Jujitsu to a
sort of a semi athletic person,
not,
uh,
not an Olympic decathlete,
but not a couch potato.
We either what would the first week look like?
And the first,
the first week would be pretty straightforward.
The things I would want someone to understand or the fundamental positions of
Jujitsu.
Jujitsu is a grappling art.
You're,
you're wrestling with another human being.
And there's certain positions and they have certain advantages and disadvantages
and so I would want them to understand these fundamental positions.
One is called the mount once called the guard,
one's called the back ones called side control.
One is called half guard and I would want people to understand what those
positions were and how they related to Jujitsu.
And the next thing I would understand is this position.
I would want my student to understand this position called the mount.
The position is a position of dominance in Jujitsu.
The person that is mounted is on the top position and they have a lot of control
over the person that's beneath them.
And you,
if you are trapped there,
you weren't a lot of trouble.
And so one of the first things I would teach people is how to escape from that
mounted position when you're on the bottom and how to get back up to their feet.
That's the next thing is how do you get back up to your feet effectively so that
you can get away.
And then I would want them to learn if they are,
if they are in the mounted position,
how would they do some kind of a submission hold?
That's one of the best things about Jujitsu is there's something called
submission holds in it where you can make the person tap out or you can break
their arm or put them to sleep through a choke hold.
So I'd want them to start to learn to understand what submissions they are
threatened with in the mouth.
That means you need to know what the offense is
and then I would want them to understand how,
how this other position,
which is called the guard and the guard is where you're on the bottom position.
So someone has taken you to the ground and you're on the bottom and they're on
top of you with their weight,
but you've managed to get your legs around their body so you have some control
over their body weight.
And then once I,
they understand how important that position is,
then I would say teach them some submissions and some sweeps,
which is when you change position you,
you put the person on,
you put your opponent on the bottom,
you were on the bottom and then you,
you sweep them and you put them on the bottom.
And the whole time that I'm teaching these things,
I think it's very important in Jujitsu that you actually spar with other people
because people need to believe that Jujitsu works.
And one of the best ways to convince people that judges who works is to actually
have them participate in it and actually have them train against another person.
That's good because when you train with someone that's good,
that's 40 pounds lighter than you and clearly weaker than you are,
and yet they can tap you out over and over and over again.
It is a real eyeopener and it will make a believer out of just about anyone.
So it's good to roll.
Now you do have to be careful because when people first start,
they go crazy.
Their ego gets out of control and everyone wants to just go 1000% against their
opponent.
So it's usually better to pair up someone against someone that's a little bit
better than them or maybe even quite a bit better than them so that they can
understand how effective it is and they can understand that no matter how much
they panic,
no match,
no matter how much they thrash around,
no matter how much they use,
all their strength.
That doesn't work in comparison to good Jujitsu technique.
So that's what it is for me.
How I would kind of have,
that's how I actually,
I do start people in Jujitsu now.
There's something else to be said.
When you go to a school,
the school whenever you go does not revolve around you just showing up there.
So you may not get this basic information.
But what's cool about Jujitsu is I look at it sort of like learning a language
and one of the best ways to learn a language is through immersion training.
And that's what's going to happen.
You show up at many Jujitsu schools,
you are going to get immersed in something.
You don't know what anything means.
Just like if you showed up in a foreign country with a foreign language,
you wouldn't understand anything at first.
And then you start to recognize a word here and a word there,
and then you recognize the little sentence fragment.
And then eventually you start putting the pieces together and then you can speak
the language.
The same thing happens in Jujitsu,
so you start recognizing a move and then you see where another move ties into it
and eventually put together a fragment of a series of moves.
And then eventually you learn the language of Jujitsu.
So it's good to get the basics of,
of all the different positions,
and there's a million places to see those online so that you'd kind of
understand fundamentally what's happening in Jujitsu.
But the immersion training is very important as well.
And you get in there,
you get on the,
on the Mat,
and you start training.
Now people also always ask,
where should I train?
What's a good school?
And there's,
I talk about this in the book and I'll go over some of the highlights of where,
how to find a good Jujitsu school.
Again,
cause I get asked this all the time.
And there's,
luckily in America there's so many really good Jujitsu schools nowadays.
Jujitsu is very popular in America.
And when I started there was very few schools in all of America and I was lucky
to have a good school in San Diego,
California.
But that has spread now and there's really good schools all over the place.
So number one thing I look at is actually proximity from home or work.
I think it's very important that wherever you're going to train as close enough
to you that you can get there conveniently without an 87 minute transit to get
there.
No,
if I've got a place that I want my place to be as close as I can,
I think that's one of the primary things you look at.
How close is it?
So it's easy to get to whether you go there after work and it's so it's close to
work or whether you go there after when when you get home,
because it's close to home either way.
But having to drive 97 minutes to get to train somewhere is not going to be
beneficial for your training.
So look for some way some where close.
The other thing is now you need to find a qualified instructor.
There's a lot of qualified instructors out there.
There's an,
and you might have a black belt and there's a lot of outstanding black belts,
but you might only have a brown belt or a purple belt depending on where you are
in the world and how much did you get to is where you are.
And so you might only have a purple or Brown Boulton and that's actually fine.
And back in the back in the 90s there were many schools in America that were run
by purple belts and they were very successful and taught a lot of great guys.
And now there's more black belt.
So that's more common as far as the legitimacy of the instructor.
You can really,
there's a lot of really good Internet police out there that keep the,
the fakers in check.
So a quick Google,
maybe ask some people,
check some forums and find out if the person is legit or not.
And that's,
that's very beneficial because you definitely want a good qualified instructor.
Now the other thing is with schools is there's two different extremes on the
schools.
There's very traditional schools and there's very nontraditional schools.
The traditional schools are,
everyone's wearing the same uniform.
Every thing is done the same structured way.
Each class the instructors are called Sensei or master or professor and,
and that's one type of school and they're great.
Some schools that are set up like that are great schools.
There's also very non traditional schools that are very loose and everyone's
wearing a different kind of uniform and people are kind of coming on and off the
mat and instead of calling the instructor,
professor or master or Sensei,
they'll just call them Jocko or dean or Jeff,
you know,
just,
it's all good.
We're all friends and we're good,
we're training hard and there was no formalities,
there's no bowing.
There's all kinds of different schools and,
and again,
both those types of schools are,
are good and they,
both those types of schools have absolutely produced world champions.
But it kind of depends on what you like,
what type of personality you have and where you think you'll fit in.
And by the way,
there's,
there's schools everywhere in between as well.
There's schools that are kind of in the gray area between the,
the very loose school to the very traditional school.
There's some schools that are in the middle.
And then you want to check that atmosphere out.
You,
what does that atmosphere like?
And does the atmosphere match the goals that you have as a person?
You know,
if you just want to learn some Jujitsu and start to train and you don't want to
compete,
but you want to know some good self defense,
Eh,
that's a one type of school.
When you can find a school with that attitude,
you can also find schools that are crazy competitive and that's all they're
focused on is sport,
Jujitsu.
And how can I win the next tournament?
And they'll have very intense training.
So,
and,
and again,
everything in between.
So you want to find a place that goes and matches your goals.
And then I would recommend you when you go into a gym,
you try some classes,
you see what they're like,
you meet the other students,
you ask the other students what their goals are in Jujitsu.
And I think you would,
you,
you can make a good decision.
And another thing is,
I always say this,
Jujitsu is,
Jujitsu is not a religion.
It's,
and your instructors are not gods.
There are people that are good at Jujitsu.
So if you start feeling there's a cult scenario happening,
just be careful that you shouldn't feel like that.
Jujitsu is fun and it's a great sport.
So you shouldn't be feeling that cult scenario happening and you shouldn't be
looking at your Jujitsu instructor as a religious deity.
Um,
so that's how you pick a school.
And,
and the book also discusses other martial arts,
boxing,
wrestling,
Moitai and like I said,
firearms training and,
and what's interesting about all these different types of training and,
and you might be thinking that I don't want,
you know,
I'm not interested in martial arts,
which is fine,
but I will tell you that first of all,
martial arts are great to train.
Not only are they great for self defense and you learn how to handle yourself,
they actually also make you a better person and a lot of different ways you're
able to handle yourself in any tough situation.
You get confident because you know you can take care of yourself and just the
physical training,
they make you sharper,
both
mentally and physically sharper and,
and tougher.
And so that's,
that's why I think training,
martial arts and Jujitsu and boxing and wrestling and,
and firearms training and all these different martial arts type training,
they,
they will help you,
not just in those specific arenas,
but in everything that you're doing in your life.
And I think that's,
I think that's really why a lot of people listened to Tim,
you know,
myself included.
We all want to hear ways to get better in every different aspect of life and the
one thing that I know will make you better is discipline.
The discipline to get up,
the discipline to work out every day,
the discipline to eat right and the discipline to make good financial decisions
and make discipline choices about how you spend your time doing productive
things.
I think that discipline is the true pathway to improvement and the like the book
says,
discipline is ultimately the pathway to freedom.
So a bunch of stuff in the book.
I appreciate everyone listening.
I supremely appreciate Tim for inviting me on to do this show while he's not
allowed to talk,
I still am.
I appreciate that and appreciate everything that Tim does and has done to
support me and what I'm doing and for continuing to put out all the great
content that he puts out to the world to help everyone out there learn,
implement and improve.
That's all I got.
Appreciate everyone listening.
Have a good one.
Y'All out.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one.
This is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour workweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and you'll get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by helix sleep.
I recently moved into a new home and when I needed beds,
where did I go?
I went to helix and I paid for them with my own monies.
I tried all sorts of mattresses.
Some of you saw me soliciting feedback and ideas on social media.
I tested a ton and I ended up on Helix.
They offer mattresses personalized to your preferences and sleeping style
without costing thousands of dollars.
It's checking out let's sleep.com forward slash Tim and you can take,
they're very simple,
two to three minutes sleep quiz to get started.
That's a diagnostic and they can build your mattress from there and ensure that
it is something you will absolutely love.
The quiz helps determine the type of mattress that is best for you by asking all
sorts of questions about your sleep behavior,
such as if you tend to lie on your back side,
stomach as well as your body type for couples.
They can even personalize each side of the mattress there.
Customer service is phenomenal.
My assistant,
my researcher,
I had them all test he likes and the customer service is really outstanding.
The mattress arrives within a week and the shipping is completely free.
You can try the mattress then for a hundred nights and if you're not happy,
they'll pick it up and offer a full refund.
It's checking out to personalize your sleep experience.
Visit Helix,
sleep.com forward slash Tim and you can get $50 off of your custom mattress.
Check it out.
He looks sleep.com forward slash.
Tim,
this episode is brought to you by legal zoom.
I've used legal zoom for many of my businesses and Matt Mullenweg as one
example.
He's been on the podcast CEO of Automattic now worth more than a billion dollars
first incorporated.
His company were on legal zoom.
When you run your own business,
you know that time equals money,
so why waste your valuable time dealing with issues that legal zoom can solve
for you?
More than 2 million people have used legal zoom to start their businesses,
but their services don't end at the beginning.
Legal Zoom has a network of independent attorneys licensed in all 50 states.
They can provide all the advice you need.
Nuts and bolts start to finish,
and you don't need to worry about billable hours because legal zoom isn't a law
firm.
That way.
You have upfront pricing and complete clarity.
Legal Zoom is a reliable resource that more than a million people have already
trusted to help them with their businesses and all sorts of different ways.
And that includes setting up will's doing a proper trademark search for me,
LLC,
sitting in the nonprofit or finding simple cease and desist letter templates.
So check them out.
Legal zoom.com take a look today to see how they can make your life better,
easier,
faster,
and more effective.
Enter Promo Code Tim Tim at checkout to save 15% that's legal zoom.com and code
Tim for 15% off.